denn ich muss dich endlich treffen
ehrlich ich sag mal was ist eigentlich
los mit dir du versteckst sich schon den
ganzen tag in dein zimmer
das kann jedoch egal sein oder du kannst
dich auch im kader kümmern das so also
gegen carla nein
carla ist mir egal aber ich hab zu tun
sag mal könnte es sein dass du einfach
süchtig bist ich schon eifersüchtig sein
sagt man glücklich ich halo 2
wo bist du denn ich hätte wirklich gerne
mit ihr gesprochen man bist ein
komischer tag
ich mache mir nur gedanken über riesa
und über alles andere auch ich bin mir
gar nicht mehr sicher ob ich das mit der
schauspielerei überhaupt noch machen
soll
das hat er alles keinen sinn vielleicht
haben meine eltern recht
ich könnte pädagogik studieren ja dann
könnte ich lehrerin werden an einer
auslandsschule in sao paulo an seiner
alten schule
das wäre bestimmt soll ach ja ruft mich
mal an ok ich will unbedingt wissen wie
das so war es dann
du kannst mit carla machen was du willst
aber vielleicht will es ist mir total
egal wirklich so könntest du mich jetzt
bitte in ruhe lassen
ich muss bei noch eine e mail schreiben
na klar mach das ein komisches gespenst
freut sich bestimmt war doch wieder nach
bonn dann stelle ich auf die
museumsmeile mit einem schild hallo ich
bin's georgio dass du etwa eifersüchtig
bist eifersüchtig wegen dir so ein
quatsch
unsinn ein unsinn ist dass du nur faul
herum liegt oder deine zeit mit
taxifahren vertrödelt du denkst
überhaupt nicht an deine zukunft
lieber lehne entschuldigen dass ich so
still wenn heute abend aber wenn du mich
herum ist frieda mir einfach die worte